rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
rejoindre les Mac par un itinéraire peu
connu le sentier du tapage qui traverse
la chaîne du bois de
nefle pour votre santé parcourez nos
sentiers
ce n'est pas vraiment par hasard que
l'on s'engage sur le sentier du tapage
logé au bout du chemin des peau à la
ligne chevalier dans les hauts de la
Rivière Saint-Louis le départ du sentier
n'est en effet pas le plus accessible
qu'il
soit cette randonnée qui conduit jusqu'à
la plaine du bois de nef au Mac vaut
pourtant le détour après une première
mise en jambe dans les champs de canne
espace privilégié décriquet la montée
proprement dite
commence
très vite le panorama se dégage sur une
partie de la côte Sud mais aussi en
contrebas sur le bras de silaos dans
lequel se loge l'îette du petit serré de
l'autre côté de la ravine l'entre deux
et surtout le massif du Dimitile de même
origine que celui du bois de nefle dont
on peut décrypter l'histoire géologique
grâce aux roches affleurantes
en traversant le le sentier du tapage
jusqu'au Mac on passe donc sur des
formations géologiques très anciennes
parmi les plus anciennes de la
réunionelle date d'entre 1200000 et
1400000 années on voit qu'elles sont
très altérées he donc le temps a fait
son son son travail et c'est pour ça
qu'on a régulièrement ici des des
éboulies après des épisodes plusvieux
c'est de la roche c'est de l'Océanite au
départ du basalte à olivine mais qui a
été complètement altéré qui fait qu'on
on ne voit même plus le la structure ni
les les cristaux à à l'UNU c'est
complètement vraiment très très dégradé
on peut voir un phénomène de de
dégradation en pelure d'oignon c'estàd
qu'on va voir des blocs rocheux qui vont
perdre des des couches successives de
l'extérieur vers l'intérieur on va on va
voir comme ça des des fragments comme de
la peau qui qui qui tombent et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de pelure
d'oignon plus haut un autre point de vue
permet de se rendre compte des
similitudes de relief entre les massifs
du bois de nefle et du dimithy à
l'instar du zèbre ou de la grande
du tapage au sol peu accidenté et fait
de petit l facile permet de vite gagner
du
dénivel comme souvent à la Réunion les
nuages peu vite se
lever foure qui matérialise la fin
deé un panorama magnifique sur toute la
côte sud mais nous n'en profiterons pas
aujourd'hui les premiers cryptos et
l'oratoire indiquent la fin de la
traversée de la chaîne du bois de nefle
le sentier bascule alors vers les maqu
une zone moins sauvage et le changement
de végétation est radical on vient de
quitter la belle forêt de transition et
ici on passe dans dans une friche en
fait qui est qui est en fait une
ancienne zone de culture à géranium qui
a été abandonné donc on a à l'époque
l'Office National des Forêts ils ont
replanté de du cryptoméa à la place pour
maintenir les sols on est dans une zone
d'envahissement maximal parce qu'il y a
enfin le courortège de végétation qui
pousse sous sous les cryptos c'est
exclusivement de l'exotique on peut
observer autour il y a du langose il y a
de la Vig marogne il y a que ça il y a
pratiquement aucune indigène à moins de
de mettre vraiment les moyens les moyens
surtout mécaniques
sera difficile de recréer une
forêt à l'intersection qui matérialise
la fin de notre randonnée plusieurs
possibilitésueer vers le pyon cabri et
la fenêtre ou vers la plaine du bois nef
ou revenir sur ses
pas
ce sentier du tapage c'est l'un des
rares sentiers qui qui permet de
d'entrer dans cette chaîne du bois de
neuf car pour le reste du
massif il est encore assez méconnu donc
en terme de botanique en terme de
prospection botanique notamment on
estime qu'il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup à découvrir dans cette chaîne
car hormis quelques quelques chasseurs
quelques barconniers de de Tang il y a
personne vraiment qui va dans cette
chaîne c'est un sentier où on peut
observer un certain nombre de Papang on
va dire que on a pu observer par le
passé plus de 10 Papang en vol simultané
dans la zone donc pour les amoureux de
de ce rapace et pour les amoureux de
pour les photographes amateurs c'est
vraiment un endroit incontournable pour
venir prendre des photos c'est un
sentier qui qui qui commence à être qui
commence à être connu parce qu'il permet
de déboucher sur des sites un peu plus
connus comme pyon cabri la fenêtre qui
est plus connue du grand public le point
négatif entre guillemets de ce sentier
c'est vra
vraiment l'accès quoi il a il y a un
petit défaut dans la signalétiique
difficile de trouver l'entrée du sentier
et en plus on a du mal à se garer donc
faut se garer en contrebas sur la route
en béton pour ensuite cheminer à pied
mais c'est vrai qu'il manque une il
manque quelques places de parking pour
que pour que les gens puissent vraiment
se garer et partir en toute quiétude à
la conquête du
sentier